this is Startalk I'm your host Neil
deGrasse Tyson your personal
astrophysicist and today we are talking
about sci-fi in literature and in movies
I got with me my coach Chuck nice Chuck
hey Neil so Chuck we had between us yes
jason Ellis who's an assistant professor
of English at New York City College of
Technology City Tech we call it and you
teach a course on science fiction that's
right they didn't do that when I was in
school there were no courses on science
we were learning all this all these
folks they were all dead and talking
about a time in a way it would with no
way understood yet they were like no
it's about real science you have to you
don't even know real science you have to
know that before you can do you have to
know real science before you write
science or Ganic liche okay so we're
talking about this relationship and
we're featuring my interview with Gale
Anne Hurd Gale Anne Hurd if you I'm a
credit watcher at the end of shows hope
some of you are use harder one of those
people it's hard cuz they roll the
movies and the movies I'm there I'm the
last one out and they asking me get the
hell out okay I tell you something
people who make films love you because
that is a the ultimate sign of respect
and you as you sit and read the credits
at the end of a film right on down to
who supplied the food right the food
truck exactly yeah
crap services bye you know Reggie Reggie
and son right so you teach a course on
science fiction and as I understand you
you curate their science fiction library
that's right we got a donation of over
600 linear feet of materials including
4,000 books by feet right if you think
of like a standard shelf as three feet
wide 300 600 feet long that's a lot of
books that's a lot of books dude and so
and so you got that so you're you're the
you're the man for that stash I hope
coordinated with the librarian um but
it's a really tremendous resource that
we have now it'll
lot of science fiction first appears in
magazines if I remember correctly is
that correct that's right more so in the
past and today but certainly is a very
vibrant publishing industry in science
fiction magazines now like astounding
science fiction's having their 90th
anniversary this year
90th anniversary man so gaily heard as a
producer and I think her first first day
on the block was the Terminator movie to
start out on start your career right
what a baptism that is did the whole
trilogy
she's got Armageddon under her belt okay
but don't get me started
violates more laws of physics per minute
than any other movie that has ever been
made laws I love it did Dante's Peak so
these are films that are different
branches of science
Dante speaker courses of volcanoes and
also did of course the Walking Dead for
television Wow so science fiction
science fantasy and so just when did you
first get it to science fiction I'm an
academic professional at it so right I
guess I've had a lot of academics it's
nothing from childhood it is is for me
to my first like strong memory I
remember is when I was three years old
watching
three years old I'm I'm in front of him
when I was three he's it's like probably
the only thing I remember from back then
but it was like in like burned on my
brain of seeing the Millennium Falcon
Deathly maneuvering between the
asteroids and a trailer for The Empire
Strikes Back when it first came out and
it was playing the drive-in and my folks
saying no we're not going to drive-in to
see that and so is this this tension of
the desire to see this fantastic you
spectacle on the screen and being told I
couldn't some then on so you got you got
imprinted yes and and is something that
stuck with me throughout the years did
you ever get to see Star Wars I did get
to see Star Wars I've seen it hundreds
thousands of times probably which medium
were you most enchanted by the film TV
or is primarily film originally and then
your television became a part of it
later on and I didn't get into my
reading science fiction until also you
learned how to read but it was strange
for me to get into
eating science fiction because I
originally you really enjoyed reading
science popularization z' like your
Weinstein's relativity Stephen Hawking's
brief history of time mirror matter
other books like that Carl Sagan his
works and it was one of my friends Marty
Magnum Boy Scouts so popular non
nonfiction science right you're talking
about who worked at local Barnes & Noble
I was having him order me new books once
the library was out of stuff that I
could read and he said you Jason you
ought to try out science fiction and so
he introduced me to Asimov and Bradbury
and Clark and got me into reading it
that's the Trinity yeah
three three of the early Grand Master
uh-huh okay really dude so of course I
had to know how Galen heard got
interested in this and so let's check it
out so I'm looking at this filmography
and his very strong overlap with the
geekus fear I am I'm a geek I'm a nerd
before there were words to describe were
you a girl nerd oh my god yes are you
kidding oh my gosh
so how early did this manifest I started
reading comic books when I was six okay
and I mean this is how geeky I am i
right I think girls did back then yeah
look at the end in the back was all four
guys know all the ads I love them all
and I admit I was a Marvel Girl okay
okay guilty as charged and then I
graduated into science fiction novels
both why a witch no I didn't exist back
then that wasn't its own category really
it was still children's children's books
and I became so obsessed with it that I
actually advised the local library this
is Palm Springs California and suggested
what books they should acquire in
science fiction/fantasy you're out ahead
of the librarians and then I started
writing book reviews predominantly about
science fiction fantasy you know people
who read a lot disappoint me if they do
not take that wisdom that they've
required and somehow share it with
others
because you're keeping all locked up
into yourself and the fact that you're
writing reviews you you've satisfied my
yo you okay by me on this you you've
you've obtained some kind of insight
into the human condition into
storytelling and then you and other
people get to know about it so I mean I
was a passion I was not only passionate
but I was proselytizing for the genre
so Jason other than sheer entertainment
is there some other value you can
ascribe to reading science fiction and I
ask that because if you read novels
people can be entertained by novels but
at the end of the day you also gain a
little extra insight into the human
condition and human emotion and love and
hate and war and peace so there's an
extra and maybe if it's embedded in a
history you learn a little bit about the
history of the world
so in sci-fi what else do you get out of
it I guess one of the things that I like
about science fiction is it combines the
STEM fields with the humanities is
technology engineering math right
exactly
and so instead of just having a story
about science and technology it looks at
how science and technology affects
individuals in society and it's through
those means that we get to your ethical
questions philosophical questions very
good I think that's one of the things
that drew me to science fiction as a kid
was my first encounter I would say
wasn't reading it was Star Trek and what
I really liked was not the spaceship and
not the fact that there were aliens but
the fact that all of mankind worked
together and I thought that was the
coolest thing in the world
that all these different people were on
this ship and they never ever talked
about their differences not one that's
interesting they never ever acknowledged
that anybody would and then they would
meet these like creepy crazy looking
aliens and they would never say like
what's up with your face you know they
would just say like some ugly
they were objectively ugly yeah they
made them objectively ugly it's so funny
but it never could became a topic and it
never but there was never anything that
like no one's appearance ever became an
issue so Jason let me ask them is sides
hold aside the reader is science fiction
a way for the writer to offer social
commentary oh certainly and I think did
Gene Roddenberry's Star Trek is an
excellent example of this where not only
are you showing how people were together
you have you equality amongst the sexism
inside the crew and also you can think
about how the the first kiss between a
white person and african-american on
television was in Star Trek and it was
largely not just you on the part of Gene
Roddenberry wanting that that moment to
happen but also the part of William
Shatner and the show and the shell
necklace you're wanting it to happen
because they would flub the takes when
they were you told not to actually kiss
for the cameras because the producers
and the studio was like we don't want to
see that on TV but you know Shatner
Nichols they kept messing up those takes
but always nailed the ones where they
were actually kissing because they knew
how important that was for people to see
that on television and of course Bill
Shatner really liked kissing well so the
weird thing is of course when they did
kiss they got mail from you know some
southern states objecting to this on
television but I don't think they ever
got mail
when Shatner was kissing the green
aliens not even human okay you're
kissing an alien so there's social
commentary but not all authors think
about that kind of effect
I presume who is that correct I would
say so but you even if someone isn't
intentionally providing some sort of
social commentary science fiction is
extrapolating from the here and now
whether it's something that's in the far
future or an alien world or even
extrapolating into the past like with
steampunk
it's everything based around the the
author's were the direct
filmmakers attitudes beliefs knowledge
etc so if so science-fiction is a
conduit to the future
and it's not only movies of course but
comic books and other media and so I
asked Gale and heard about whether any
of this background that she enjoyed with
science fiction influenced her choice of
movie that she that she elected to
produce listen you know at the risk of
stating the obvious
your your your geek roots in comics
comic book stories science fiction they
manifest in this filmography strongly so
how what do you what the hell you how
are you doing I make what I'd like to
see and my newest show is falling water
for USA Network which is I have yet to
see that but everybody's telling me to
see it it is everybody fantastic
everybody so why weren't you listening
to them ok tonight
I'll dig ok tonight thank you you know I
feel bad I got to know what the pulse is
out there
it's it because it is I mean if you if
you liked inception that was a great
amuse-bouche
mm-hmm for Fallingwater because good
inception these are the nested dreams of
reality and we're following in following
water we're following three different
characters who are all seeking something
something that's missing from their
lives there's a shared dream among them
or something
it turns out that one of the conceits of
the show is that we're all dreaming
separate tiles of a large mosaic and
certain powerful dreamers can leave
their dream and enter yours or mine or
anyone's and just think of the power
that that will have and how valuable
they will become to people who want more
control than they already have over the
world so Jason the
can you assess the causes and effects of
the chicken egg technology shown or
imagine in science fiction does it
become real is something that we do in
science that then gets adopted but they
taken another step what is that
relationship I think is a very complex
relationship one where both feed into
each other's like a feedback loop that
works in both directions so as science
and technology create new innovations
those things get incorporated into the
science fiction that we enjoy in the
comic books that we enjoy but at the
same time people come up with new ideas
try to stretch the boundaries of
possibility such as Jerry Pournelle
hittin forget the other author's name
the wrote a book in 1970s the mode in
God's eye and they imagine the mote in
God's eye in which they you imagined
personal computers pocket computers that
you would carry around and the your 30
40 years later then we had that reality
right you know it's funny because Jeff
Bezos just did a interview ahead of
Amazon hey no man was I did an interview
where he talked about Alexa being
inspired by the way people talk to
computers in the sci-fi movies and and
TV shows that he saw when he was a kid
and and I thought of that I was like
that's so funny like in all sci-fi
people talk to the computer they go
computer working you know it's like so
and now we do that it's almost always a
female for and it's but even 2001 space
like he's talking to the cow you know
I'm sorry dude like you know I can't do
that
right so it's weird that we now actually
do that we take it for granted that we
say you know okay Google or hey Alexa or
Siri and we take it for granted it's so
weird but I would say that it is not
just that one-way street of science
fiction imagining this new possibility
and it comes reality but also that the
things that that that are discovered the
new things that are found in science and
technological innovation also feed their
way back into science fiction because
the thing is like we
really the way like the iPad works are
really the way that Alexa works the way
that we understand it now wasn't
envisioned in science fiction we we can
trace it back and see where there might
be a little bit of inspiration but it
wasn't the thing itself so this is the
complex elements it's more a tapestry of
information coming together this rain as
opposed to a linear track that you can
establish right there's a really good
example of this if I can shared with HG
Wells in 1909 he wrote the land
ironclads a story about the first modern
battle tank and it was some years later
in 1911 or so that major-general Swinton
and then to the tank for the British
military you with the advent you or it
led into the advent of World War one
later
well sued Swinton claiming ownership of
that invention of the tank luckily
didn't have to go that far but Wells did
lose that court case and I think rightly
so because even though he was able to
show that that Swinton had read The
Strand Magazine that the story appeared
in his science fiction is something that
I think can inspire give people ideas it
can provide motivation for new research
but it isn't necessarily like the actual
patent application but I take a break
when we come back more of my interview
with Gale Anne Hurd the producer of
really cool we're back Startalk this
episode all about science fiction as its
represented in film comics television
featuring my interview with Gale Anne
Hurd who's a prodigious producer of just
this kind of product and 4-digit
producer of this kind of product let's
pick up where I just asked her about how
much does she think about the accuracy
of science in sci-fi films let's check
it out I'm looking at the you know the
Terminator aliens alien nation the abyss
that was all underwater there and and
this just goes on and on on Armageddon
I gotta tell you my relationship with
Armageddon so let me say of Armageddon
that I found the movie thoroughly
entertaining just the writing the timing
that mixture of actors the wit the the
emotion it was just fun okay I'm just
that's my first of all comments that
being said in my community Armageddon is
one of the films we reference in science
class for how many laws of physics are
violated well what's really funny is the
last thing I was worrying about was if
an asteroid was coming that people have
decided that that some of the science in
our again which we know is fo science it
was actually like not the worst we were
not the worst okay I probably have
another one in there and by the way that
we could spend an entire hour on Dante's
Peak I mean the oaken ologists because
this is the thing so we were like we're
here we have a Cascades Volcano
they don't have lava it's part class two
clothes etc and and this plastic flows
so so so the studio which will go and
mention said no no volcanoes have
it's like there are different kinds of
volcano easier we had a volcanologist
named Jack Lockwood who was fantastic
and I kept saying you know I kept
sending him scripts saying I'm sorry I
can't get this changed so we tried to
get other things right in terms of the
earthquakes and the and the pyroclastic
flow that we did have let's bring in a
geologist I've got a Janine [ __ ] nur on
skype Janine welcome to Startalk thank
you very much
so you're a volcanologist hmm so this
was this is you know Spock live long and
prosper Tony
volcanologist with the Smithsonian
global volcanism program that's actually
a thing and also a science communicator
and blogger for in the company of
volcanoes and it you haven't melted yet
or anything you just you want to these
people who walks up to volcanoes and
studies them yes I study the park
listing Fleur side of things so you're
exactly your expertise is where Dante's
Peak got it exactly wrong are they got
it well the park lets it flow is great
oh so they were able to include paradise
to flow with blah blah but the lava part
was false for that particular volcano
yes so briefly tell us about pyroclastic
flow Chuck knows it for the rest of us
I'm gonna go get some coffee now because
you know pyroclastic flows I mean that's
where I'm the biking exactly
go Chuck just left for coffee not going
so tell us about it it's this really
fast really hot cloud of hot gas and hot
volcanic rock so it's basically a racing
cloud of death that goes on a volcano
and can destroy everything in its path
so they showed that very very well in
the movie in fact that was the scene
where I watched it as a 13 year old girl
going that's what I'm gonna study for
the rest of my life Wow
talk about inspiration that is cool so
just to clarify listen to what she just
said she said I saw this rolling cloud
of hot death and I want to study that
girls do very cool so so how would you
generally rate the science in Dante's
Peak is it one of the best volcano
movies cuz you know there's the Pompeii
has been done five or six times you know
since the you know since movies could be
made where would you rank that top by a
very big margin oh okay
high praise from Caesar
so in Dante's Peak what would you say
they did best and what would you say
they did worst the best I mean I'm a bit
biased but the pie clastic flow was
fantastic the ash plume was great the
ash spreading out over the town was
fantastic the uncertainty around the
eruption as its leading towards eruption
is pretty good the monitoring that the
using the different tools like
seismicity measuring the gas is
fantastic
not so great was the volcanic ash of a
major beef with the volcanic ash and of
course the lava flow that's the volcanic
elephant in the room and they did the
aloha really great through that mud flow
that wiped out the bridge and killed our
fearless leader unfortunately and with
the outrunning of the pyroclastic flow
so they make it into the mineshaft it
looks like everything's okay really that
really hot scorching gas cloud probably
what it got meant that there in the end
so what was the problem with the ash you
said I had a real problem with the
volcanic ash what why they have used wit
newspaper
so it looks fluffy and really soft but
in reality volcanic ash is pulverized
rock crystals and glass so it's really
nasty stuff it can collapse rubes that
can cause breathing issues you do not
want it in your eyes it's horrible so
ash is just the wrong word it's the
wrong word it's not as yeah it's it's
volcanic glass volcanic pins-and-needles
yeah volcanic shard charge
that's what hears bulk annex shards so
minik do me minutes yeah so how about
the bad
among the science folk in the movie
because that takes research to get that
right how do they do there I think they
did pretty good especially the coffee
addiction that's a really important part
of being a scientist probably in many
fields for nature of dr. Harry Dalton is
a bit too much we would always want more
data we wouldn't want to go straight and
skier they crap other towns people
that's that's not what we do and until
you have enough data to do so right
don't play like you don't want to scare
the crap out of the townspeople because
you know that's one of the parts of your
job you enjoy most
so just to just repeat you you're you
are certifying Dante's Peak with all of
its shortcomings as being the finest
scientific the most representatively
accurate volcano movie ever made head
and shoulders above all others including
gel in the volcano Joe in the doctor and
Volcanology yes yes I do
cool and could the fact that New Zealand
has had some unfortunate encounters with
earthquakes in recent decades
Christchurch being almost completely
destroyed has that had an influence on
your curiosity about the raging earth I
was actually on my way long before that
I look a lot younger than I really am
[Laughter]
but now living in New Zealand I grew up
around volcanoes so I always loved
bouquet noise since I was Josh since
before I could remember sorry the
landscape I grew up in is to claim it in
effect can I ask a question
um just unrelated to sci-fi this is
actually very very real there are some
people who advocate for the denial of
climate chaos and being human caused by
humans that say that volcanoes are kind
of the culprit here that they dump more
co2 co2
into the atmosphere then anything else
could ever do so and that we're wasting
our time trying to mitigate human
activity with respect to producing
carbon what do you say to those people I
can see why people think that in fact
people don't even realize just how much
activity there is when they think that
but in reality volcanoes on land and
underwater produce less than 1% of
carbon dioxide than people do so it's
true on any on any yeah it's just not so
so let me bring this to a close and ask
you is there some volcano movie that you
can imagine wanting to consult on that
takes it in another direction or it's
uncharted territory for the science
fiction media goodness that's a good
question we've done the supervolcano
thing that's been over killed
how about underwater volcanoes or ice
volcanoes is we have on some of the
moons of Jupiter astronauts on a planet
that has ice volcanoes how about that
that's a good actually I'm I will see
that movie because because you know we
think of volcanoes as a place where hot
things come out of right
but it's only a place where there's high
pressure and you can have high pressure
on a place where that's very cold right
where something boils at a hundred
degrees below zero right all right and
so now everything is icy to us but you
have high pressure volcanic
circumstances on these other other
places okay so if we get that that will
make sure you are on the list for there
consult consultants yeah I would
absolutely consult there need to be more
scientists consulted on movies as I'm
sure you will agree well excellent so
thanks for coming up bringing your
expertise to us my pleasure
excellent ok thank you that was a very
cool she was very cool yes like the idea
of the volcanoes that's right but Jason
do you have any volcanic sci-fi
literature that you did not in
literature than like making 67 what yeah
you dig it that's right I'm a mad cat
I say the same thing to my students they
probably don't know what I'm talking
about I don't know why I just turned in
the Sammy Davis jr. you didn't turn it
Sammy Davis you turn it to Austin Powers
[Laughter]
what volcanoes do you dig well I can't
think of any in literature that I've
read about but I'm thinking in terms of
the movie that you just pitched to the
volcanologists that we spoke with Europa
report
it seemed like part of the story centers
on like how unstable the surfaces where
they land on Europa which those you you
could either see or maybe turn different
ways to be like ice volcanoes and then
hear danger of studying an environment
like that cool you know how I know about
the Europa report no because I'm in it
[Music]
what are you doing it's it was a cheap
shot
so at first it's a it's a it's a nicely
done lower budget sci-fi film okay and
it's called the Europa report they try
to take a different angle on how you
might make a movie so this is a mission
to Europa to see if there's life there
right and the entire movie are just the
cameras stitched together from the camp
the different cameras in the ship and
outside the ship so throughout the
entire movie camera three camera six
summer walks with it camera eight and so
it is the report of this mission
assembled by basically the video cameras
positioned around the ship so that's
that's the that's the the premise for it
okay and they use a clip of me being
interviewed by the news saying I want to
go to Europa because it has an icy
surface and an ocean below and I want to
cut a hole and go ice fishing and you're
Oprah see if anything swims up to the
camera lens so they use that clip of
name but that's not what it paid me to
like a thousand dollars I said yeah okay
do it right so it was an interesting
attempt and you're right that surface is
very unstable because it's ice sheets
floating on water that is being heated
and their heat sources and so
when you heat water under ice the ice is
not stable it breaks it refreezes and
you can have a phenomenon then what you
might not otherwise be thriller with
that's cool right yeah I think that they
they see the Fisher's change yes yeah on
your rope yes
and that's how they know that this ice
is melting and refreezing and melting
and refreezing and if you find life on
Europa and will call it no Europeans
[Laughter]
[Music]
take our next break when we come back
more on Startalk we're talking about
sci-fi in movies TV and literature we're
back start off Neil deGrasse Tyson here
a personal astrophysicist by the way we
are recording this in my office of the
Hayden Planetarium of the American
Museum of Natural History right here in
New York City better known as the cosmic
crib the cosmic we haven't done some
cosmic cosmic come back to cosmic
creation do some episodes we got Chuck
nice of course that's right Jason
professor the professor sci-fi you know
that should not be allowed that's too
fun that is a pretty cool time how many
how many kids take your class is it one
of the more popular class it's one of
the more popular classes yeah look how
he's so casual yeah just happy to be on
all of campus I've taught in Georgia
Tech as well as here at City Tech and
students always want to sign up for it
very very cool well we're featuring my
interview with Gail and heard what one
of these highly prolific producers of
really innovative science fiction
material from the Terminator trilogy
riding up through the Walking Dead on
television which went through how many
to tens how many seasons was that up to
clearly she's not
it's a shame she hasn't come into her
own she's got to figure out it's just a
figure in life everything it's okay so
so I had to ask her what was it like to
work in two completely different media
television where there are multiple
stories that or you can develop more
subtleties within a story over many
episodes and a movie we got to go and
get the job done and get out so I have
to understand how does that work let's
check it out what I've discovered having
been both a feature film producer and a
television producer is that with a
feature you spent two maybe three years
making a two and a half hours it's a
one-shot deal and so you've got to get
all that character in you got to get all
that plot and you got it
wrap it all up so the television series
we have ten hours so those ten
installments
yes there are 10 episodes was a 10 hour
movie it's essentially yes
so we get to learn so much more about
the characters dive so much more deeply
not only into that but into the
mythology into the world and into the
conceit of the storytelling yes and and
the stakes are so much greater because
you can unfold them and you know unspool
it more slowly and get more and more
invested because when you do a movie and
you have to get all of that out in the
our avatars it looks very forced
we open up a character and that's one of
the constraints of medium and television
is much different you know you can once
you're connected you know there's going
to be so much more I mean the idea I
mean like let's say a film like
Inception there's not a sequel so if you
really wanted to follow these characters
into the future that's not happening or
if it does it'll happen you know five
ten years later
so Tommy Jason tell me about the
difference between developing a cool
science tech storyline and developing
the characters within the story because
it's clear that a movie has a harder
time developing people than a 10 hour
movie
or a 10 hour TV series would so how does
a consumer of this medium and a teacher
know that how do you how do you split
that
well whenever you're thinking about like
television obviously you have a lot more
time to develop not only the characters
but do the world-building necessary for
the audience to really engage in the
ideas of the show like with Star Trek
for example but where's like a film you
have to jump right in and get straight
to the point
otherwise you could either lose the
audience or it could slow the pace of
the film down so much that the audience
begins dozing off also another issue
that relates both to series and film has
to do with novels that when you write a
novel or short story you can provide
interior tea you can provide the
thoughts of the characters which you
can't really do on film or in television
other than like a flashback awkward
waves in awkward ways exactly except
Japanese anime where they're always
doing that that's all they do is give
you the interior is always what the
characters thinking at all times that
word interior so it's interesting that
the the how clumsy it can be to get
inside someone's head without having
them be a whispered narration over their
thoughts so what's what's the mechanism
as a writer that you can use to portray
like the the thought patterns of a
character without doing that you know
that though they're showing the close-up
of the face it's just like and they look
off it and there's just like this happen
like you know how what can you do well
they'd be really good actors can convey
those emotions just by their facial
expression oh my god you're absolutely
right yeah like Meryl Streep I think
that's one of her strongest points but
you're exactly right that things about
like nonverbal information from facial
expressions the way person carries
themselves the tone the tonality of
their voice but also your film
techniques like the Simon cinematography
the way the shot is framed the colour
scaled issues for background or
foreground and obviously music is the
biggest you don't have it
right right and this is the thing is not
to say that one medium is superior to
another each of them have different
affordances things that they can do and
constraints things that they can't do in
order to tell a story and I think a
master for a storyteller uses the the
mediums affordances to their maximum
capability to and to it to be able to
tell the story but also involve the
audience and those emotions and those
characters I have two words today so so
nowadays with streaming services where
they'll drop an entire series of all at
once do you think the future of sci-fi
is bright because now sci-fi can have
the same kind of treatment as other long
dramatic stories that have been dragged
out for multiple episodes have done in
the past I think so like maybe a good
example would be the expanse oh gee I'm
sorry I'm sorry I didn't give you that
affordance I get very excited but that
is a trim if you have people listening
if you get the chance
watch the experience I found it by
mistake and four days later I was
sitting there unshaven and smelly you
know but they do the science well but
who's streaming this
I think it's Amazon if I'm not good but
they do the science well and it was cool
because you know I sit at the feet of
the master all the time here and I get
to hear and learn a lot about what
really happens in space and one of the
things that they do very well is let you
see that in zero gravity you are a
helpless little majorca me I yours is
one of most helpless stay or get
everything and they do it really well
but anyway I'm sorry I got excited I
interrupted you go ahead but you make a
really good point about like you
stumbled on to it by mistake right and I
think that with streaming services in
this new way that we're consuming media
actually may introduce science fiction
to more people now because they just
stumble on to things or try something
out in a way that was harder to do in
the past where you
to tune into the channel at a certain
day a certain time and if you didn't
well then just you totally missed it but
now with things being shared on social
media recommendations or things that you
find just browsing through Netflix or
Amazon and I'm gonna jump in the middle
if they can start at the beginning
exactly right so you got it right and
the cool thing about the experience is
they take the geopolitical relationships
between countries that we have right now
and they expand that to become inter
solar relationships between people who
are born in the asteroid belt in the in
the Kuiper know people who are born on
Mars at 30% gravity and earthers who are
and so over this long period of time
human beings have kind of you know not
really born on earth are they birthers
[Laughter]
yeah and it's really it's very it's very
funny because the prejudices that we
hold towards one another here on earth
now just becomes different prejudices
that we hold towards each other based on
where which planet or which reason of
the solar system that you're born so
Jason let me ask you are there untapped
possibly low-hanging fruit available for
the sci-fi author now that we have these
media these new ways of delivering
storytelling I think so and your Netflix
has jumped to this like with the the
streaming of series black mirror they
take new new things that we're all very
familiar with and just push it a little
bit into the future near future science
fiction so though it so that it's you
can almost touch it rain but not quite
right just almost touch it enough to
scare the bejesus out of you right right
yeah but it's it's through that you this
this platform of being able to stream
you a series of movies were just
watching one individual episode yeah I
think it Merces people in these ideas
and gets them thinking about them in a
way that science fiction is given to as
opposed to other media words it's more
just about a dramatic story so there's
another aspect to this storytelling that
I think I briefly discuss
with Gail and her and it has to do with
not only are you imagining the science
but how much of the science are you
getting right and what value that might
have to your audience let's check it out
I think and I'd like to get your your
verification of this or falsification I
think we live in a time where if you get
the science right there is an entire
other following that the movie will pick
up in the blogosphere where people
compliment the science that it gets
right and it gets talked about for
months beyond the normal marketing
period like the Martian
like the Martian like the Martian and so
I'd like to believe that gone are the
days we just make stuff up because you
think it looks better and then you
alienate an entire community of people
who could have praised you for doing it
accurately and and the more we are in
this error that I'm thinking we're
entering the more pressure there is on
producers directors to bring in a
scientist and maybe by the way we had
scientists on each of those films I
don't believe you had a single scientist
on Armageddon we've had multiple
features from NASA and in fact we even
shot in the neutral buoyancy in Houston
yes yes that's a the fact there's a
whole scale model of the Hubble
telescope submerge there so that the
astronauts who would be servicing it
that you know it's kind of it's not
perfect zero-g but you get that floaty
feel to it and so yeah all right that's
good that good but I'm saying I am NOT
at least we knew that we were breaking
those laws so Jason how do you feel when
you see bad science in a film I don't
think it's necessarily always a bad
thing but I would say that it's
unfortunate today because obviously
audiences are more well educated and I
think there is a certain expectation
that the science is right but I do agree
with me about the blogosphere there's a
whole geek community that cares about
real science oh I think that you're
absolutely right about that but I can
also say as a warning like when sunshine
by Danny Boyle was released I saw it in
theatres in Liverpool England and after
the film was over I was complaining to
all my friends quite vocally about how
bad the science was in parts of it
especially about like restarting the Sun
and unbeknownst to me so I didn't see
the movie but they restart that sounds
kind of cool though it's kind of cool
except that it's very small like nuclear
package that they used to kickstart
things but what I unbeknownst to me was
that Danny Boyle's family was sitting in
the row behind me and they kind of
leaned over and gave me some dirty looks
and made me a little uncomfortable and I
thought about it and I it's obviously a
tremendous success for someone to be
able to make a film right to rely on all
our system at all right but I do think
that you if you were going to be putting
these millions of dollars toward making
a film why not make it a film that has
more real science that can teach people
as well as entertain them true true I
mean you sometimes it's a what's the
movie where they basically play around
with the tenets of string theory and
Matthew McConaughey interstellar thank
you yes and so I I loved all the
questions that they posed in the movie
but then it comes down to love so I
never thought about it till this moment
maybe
interstellar spent too much time on
getting their science right and not
enough time on the emotion and the
interpersonal stories right that would
be embedded within it yeah there's a
balance a balance it's gotta be
otherwise yeah so you can praise it for
its science but then if there's no story
or if the story is not otherwise
convincing novelistic lee then what do
you have at the end of the day because I
think we're all fundamentally
storytellers story listeners even as
adults you
absolutely yeah I think its core to
being a human being yeah is really
stories you know related to this is Hugo
Gernsback the father of science fiction
started the first science fiction
magazine in April 1926 amazing stories
and he defined science fiction in part
as being 75% romance and 25% science and
so even from that beginning point of
what we think of as modern science
fiction there was this idea that you you
have to have a balance between being a
would tell a story that it's about
people while bringing in to show how
science and technology influences and
affect people and how people respond to
those challenges do I think of this is
yeah you should try to get the science
right but don't don't let that stop your
creativity but often there's newly
discovered science in any branch of
science that might be more creative on
its frontier then you can be trying to
make stuff up so why not reach for that
edge my field we that edge overflows we
gave you wormholes black holes the
vacuum of space antimatter
that's photons lasers we that's we gave
you that Jason do you see him bragging I
don't mean to brag but so but because I
can tell you there's a famous quote from
JBS Haldane and it's the universe is not
only stranger than we have imagined it
may be stranger than we can imagine
which to me says that there's no greater
source of material to mine or science
fiction storytelling then the scientist
is oh just make sure you get that three
quarters romance and that is a cosmic
perspective you've been listening to
possibly even watching this episode of
star talk I want to thank you Jason
Thank You Chad yes for this episode
thank you guys this is great okay and
until next time as always I bid you to
keep looking up
you